gatabaya rajapaksa has fled sri lanka
and landed in the maldives after failing
to escape to his first choice
destination dubai the former president
resigned on wednesday designating the
prime minister ranil wick remsaga as the
new acting president he has declared a
state of emergency a curfew and police
have deployed tear gas to disperse
crowds of protesters still out on the
streets
people do not seem ready to embrace the
country's new leader
oh yes i definitely want both resign and
i think a new regime needs to come into
place and i think sri lanka still has
hope
even if the prime minister becomes
president he has no mandate
the president had some of the people's
support
which remy singer does not have the
support of the people at all
and we're not prepared to recognize him
as the
the
president
should realize
the power of the people and they should
listen to the people's
commands
after storming other government
buildings protesters turned their
attention to the prime minister's office
dw's meniere chaudhry was at the scene
in the sri lankan capital colombo well
yes i'm right on the same street where
the prime minister's office is located
we're just coming from there they are
all over the place there are hundreds of
people inside the premise of the prime
minister's office they are cheering they
are raising slogans they are raising the
flag of sri lanka they are sitting atop
on the roofs of the prime minister's
office so they have finally managed to
force their way inside
i've been to sri lanka to colombo
multiple times and every time i've come
the situation has gotten worse we have
seen rows and queues of people outside a
few stations outside cooking gas station
they're not able to get anything the
prices of the medicines that shot up the
ambulance services have announced that
they can't cater to every area because
they are also out of fuel so the crisis
has only deepened but the thing is that
the economic crisis will not be
stabilized till the time the country
finds some stability in the politics in
the government so that is what is
remaining right now
joining us is amber kasakunanathan
former human rights commissioner of sri
lanka thanks for joining the program
thank you for having me
i'm curious what happens next is anyone
really in charge
yes technically the president has still
not resigned
and uh while he is out of the country he
has
appointed the prime minister ranil
vikrama singha as acting president and
the speaker has also announced that the
president has informed him that during
the course of today he will submit his
resignation so if and when the president
submits his resignation
then automatically the prime minister
becomes the interim president and
they've already announced the date for
the reconvening of parliament which is
the 15th and the nominations to be filed
for parliament in parliament for the
president to be chosen by parliament
that's on the 19th and on the 20th they
will vote to elect the president who
will then serve out the rest of the term
of uh
you know the current of the current
president
now among the protesters in terms of
what they
want is their consensus uh moving
forward or there or is there a diversity
of opinions from people who've taken to
the streets for for months
well the protesters there are so many
different groups and there is a group
that has generally been you know for
over 90 days at uh gota go gamma in
colombo then there are various other
protests taking part in different parts
of the taking place in different parts
of the country
and the only consensus that we can see
until now is that they want the
president to resign and they want the
prime minister to resign at the moment
that appears to be the only consensus
and the main demand so as we speak there
are thousands of protesters outside uh
prime minister and well now acting
president rani will be promising his
office demanding that he stepped down
the the police have
used and the military have used water
cannons they have used tear gas against
them and the situation there right now
is quite tense
quite a fast developing situation i want
to take a step back i mean gotabaya
rajapaksa was part of a political
dynasty we've talked about this before
his brother was the former finance
minister who's also
fleeing other than their exile
will there be any accountability
from this family or do you think they
have escaped the law
well sri lanka doesn't have a good track
record with accountability
whether it is in relation to corruption
or in relation to wartime violations and
therefore whether in country any members
of this family will be held accountable
is doubtful
i feel that particularly given the
president uh involvement in wartime
violations the allegations against him
that there is probably a
higher likelihood of the president at
least being held accountable outside the
country than inside the country that's
very interesting something to watch uh
in the coming months
ambika sakunanathan thank you so much
for joining us as always
thank you very much
the political crisis is hitting citizens
at the pump with record high prices
in an effort to conserve fuel the
government is asking people to work from
home and has closed schools
restaurants have even switched to
cooking meals with wood
here's a closer look at how people are
enduring life in sri lanka
for seven days azam mohadin has been
waiting here in a kilometer long line
for gas in sri lanka's capital colombo
he'd heard a new fuel delivery was
coming he spent day and night here since
there is simply no more fuel
we have no more gas at home to cook
we used to have an income but for weeks
now the money has stopped coming
we can't go on like this
life is hard
to make matters worse his wife is ill
he tries to spend a little time with her
every day at lunchtime
risking losing his place in line
i keep calling him when he is there
waiting it's the tormenting thoughts
that have made me sick i was even
admitted to hospital
we didn't even have fuel for him to
drive me there
many people in sri lanka face similar
problems inflation is soaring and prices
are skyrocketing even for essentials
like food
hardly anyone can afford to buy what
they need
people used to have three meals a day
most of the time
now it's either two or one
sometimes people are drinking water
instead of eating
we don't know what to do what to give
our children they say they're hungry but
we don't have anything for them
we can't drink tea with milk anymore we
have no milk powder
we just about managed to buy rice but
even that is very expensive
another day has gone by in the line for
gas
and for azam
it's again been fruitless
his one hope that after the resignation
of president gotabaya rajapaksa better
times will finally come
only when we get problems like the fuel
crisis solved can we live a life worth
living
i haven't lost faith yet that a new
government will give us fresh hope and
change will finally happen
until then azam mohadin will spend
another night in line hoping that he
will finally get a few litres of fuel
you